hello everyone and welcome to a most
interesting game from the chess 24
banter blitz Cup
it's French grandmasters real massage
versus a young shoe stove Duda and it's
it's quite the game I saw the final
position just 24 tweeted about it said
it was the spectacular ending to a
spectacular game and then I saw the
entire game and I said to show it and
I'm sure gonna be very very interested
in this one and also I would just like
to mention I was a guest on a podcast
yesterday at mr. quoth the Raven so if
you want to check it out I will put a
link to it in the description below it
will be the first thing you see so it's
it's about an hour long so maybe if
you're if you have an hour extra on your
hands maybe maybe you'd be interested in
that so that being said let's check out
this game moose are opens with Knight to
f3 the rate the opening with c5 by Judah
sorry about that
inviting white the transpose into the
Sicilian woody for maybe but g3
continuing in the spirit of the red team
with Knight f6 Bishop to g2 and b6 now
that black also prepares the finger to
the light square Bishop and although you
could go 495 open up a discovery here
black would be very happy to block it
with d5 and already having a d5 in makes
like I said black very happy
so just fix this so castles by Mozart
and Bishop the b7 a countering White's
light square Bishop and c4 this is all
still the main line we have g6 and b3
now both players prefer to Fink yet or
both of both of their bishops we have
Bishop to g7 Bishop to b2 and now black
castles as well and here we have a
perfectly symmetric symmetrical position
with d4 by white and here the symmetry
ends although there are some games in
the database were black followed up with
the symmetry would be 5 black had had no
success in any of those games so some of
the games were drawn but most of them
were lost
so instead seek a person d4 still
considered the main line Queen captures
and d4 and now Knight to c6 developing
with an attack on the Queen Queen to f4
in the in the past Queen to d2 was it
was the go
to move but now queen a4 in the d5 now
finally black gets v5 in rook to d1
although if maybe instead of this d5
also a queen trade offer would queen to
be it was possible but here first d5 by
Duda rook to d1 now pinning the the pawn
here and now Quint the c8 Quinta b8 is a
no move in this position but Queen to
see it is a new move so already as a
move 11 we have a completely new game so
let's see what happens here we have
Knight to c3 continuing development
putting pressure on the pawn here and do
DuBose in Knights to h5 opens up his
dark square Bishop and also puts an
attack on the on the White Queen here
Queen to h4 and now Bishop to f6 kicking
the Queen away even further back so the
e7 point is not under pressure for the
moment the knight defends it but you
don't want to worry about that in the
future after all it is a blitz game so
Queen h3 now offering a queen trade and
first d captures on c4 now if you
recapture Knight a5 you're gonna win
this point as well
so instead Mossad does this as a pawn
sacrifice so rook a to c1 he gives up
this point as well do the captures that
it captures and Queen captures on h3 now
Bishop captures and h3 and now just rook
after da Duda is up upon and he counters
white rook on the open D file we have
grouped after sandy 8th route capture
sandy 8 and now Bishop to a3 again puts
pressure on the on the e7 pawn but here
Duda has a very interesting move he
gives up the dark square Bishop which is
odd it's it's an incredibly strong
leadership but he has he has an idea
Bishop captures and c3 rook captures on
c3 and now rook to d1 with chick and now
King to g2 Bishop to f1 was a was a bit
more resilient bulky King to g2 and now
Knights the d4 opening up a discovery
here so the knight is pinned you cannot
move it and also there's Knight captures
and he do in the position well there's a
lot of it in the position so black has
to decide whether he where he can
capture on e7 maybe he wants to go rook
to c7 a lot of options here so mossad
goes for rook to c7 goes after the
appear and Duda has to now decide even
though it's a blitz game there are a
couple of options that you definitely
need to consider one of them is Knight
captures here and the other one is
Bishop captures here so Knight captures
an f3 is very interesting because White
has the recapture and that's that's
important because if you capture here
then you get nice the e1 with Czech you
block the f3 square with the night so
the King has to go back f1 g1 or h1
doesn't really matter but now Knights
see to check opens up a discovery and
picks up the bishop here on a3 so black
would just be up a piece and completely
winning but do this solution is even
better
he played Bishop captures on f3 wit
check
we have eke a present f3 and now feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the absolutely brilliant move Duda
played while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
unsporting a really brilliant move and
for those who just won't enjoy the show
it's not Knight to e2 if Knight to e2
threatening mate yes it looks scary but
after f4 white just creates a Sun
breeding Square for Ace King and you no
longer have an attack but if you found
Knight to f4 with check then you you you
got it right
so here you triple white spawns this is
the only move as your King cannot move
and only now Knights the e2 and now
there's no F to remove the free D F 3
square for the King so your only options
here are well there aren't a lot of them
Bishop to g4 was played in the game
freeing the h3 square 4 with the White
King
your other option is just rook here
preventing rook to g1 mate but even then
you after captures captures captures
it's a completely winning and game for
black so not much point in trying that
so good job the g4 was played freeing
the h3 Square for the White King but now
rook the g1 check King h3 and Knight
captures on f4 forcing the King up the
board with King to h4 and now the the
beautiful f6 now g5 is the threat of
checkmate and there's not much you can
do here Bishop to e6 check was played
trying to trying to get black to capture
the threesome squares around the white
but of course to do that just played
King to h8 with rook the CHF King g7 and
now even the rook the g8 width trip came
to h6 now do the skin joins the attack
and now there is nothing to do against
the g5 and it was in this position
unmoved xxx that humans are resigned to
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here well there is but it would be
it would be very pointless you could
capture something like Bishop character
Sunday 7 and after g5 started giving up
pieces rook captures captures and after
captures just captures but in the end
you're done a whole rook and you are
most likely well not most likely but
you're going to lose this game
terribly sir after King t6 Mossad
resigned the game and a brilliant
victory for young sister Duda in the
chest 24 banter blitz match which he won
and he he goes into the D well next part
of the competition yeah that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it like I said if
you have an hour extra to check out do
check out link in the description below
as like I said I was a guest on the
course of the Ravens podcast we had we
had a lot of good laughs we had we have
a good time so maybe maybe we'll be
interested in there as well but yeah I
would like to think James Abraham ranch
neither a Hector Coronado Cody Holden
and Morton the restorer for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos you're
thinking for watching and I will see you
soon are continuing the coverage of the
pole movie saga we do have to check out
the finals of the first American chess
congress checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and of course whatever else
happens in the chess world
the candidates are almost here so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest your day